so let's enter the crunch real quick
oh look at that what a time to be alive
look we have a lot of problems in this
country but my god is our snack
selection amazing
[Music]
hey everyone i'm hussa minhaj and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
tim let's do it again tim
tim let's let's do it again
listen
listen tim i was just at conde nast they
don't let it fly like that at conde nast
there we go let's go jim
all right first up chester's fries
i don't know what the difference between
chester's fries and flamin hot cheetos
are i think chester's fries has a
different
um
texture than
the flamin hot cheeto it's a little bit
more put together it actually does
resemble the shape of a sweet potato fry
i'm gonna use
um some gloves complex stole this um
from a bunch of frontline workers
this bit this has quickly become ncis
snack edition this pinky is doing a
weird thing but let's just act like it's
not i should know better i took sex ed i
saw this
we all did mrs ledington showed me this
with the banana okay
i actually prefer these
to the flaming hots i actually think
it's a lot cleaner and easier to eat i'm
already telling you these gloves are
clutch look at all this that's on my
fingertips i'm 35 years old like if i
walk around with just red powder on my
fingertips it's a really bad luck we go
from sloppy
professional
oh wait
i gotta go on a zoom meeting of course
i can go right on my trackpad
ooh
shout out to the indian community parley
g cookies
[Music]
this is major comedian of your last has
a whole bit about parley g cookies
um i don't know who
this little baby is
but
i hope
this baby's family is just raking it in
because
this is like the indian gerber baby you
have no idea like this is so iconic and
from my childhood it's a snack that
parents will give their kids there's
some people that will have a cup of chai
they'll dip it in the chai they've now
started to put this on top of like
indian ice cream sundaes
so they'll do like a vanilla or a
pistachio ice cream
with parley g cookie crumble on it
oh it's so good
i really hope we
as indians invented this i hope this can
come from the british there's one thing
that i hope we had i hope we invented
these ourselves this tastes like
childhood
do can we get a shot at tim
pan over to him real quick
okay
no this is this is actually important
for the story tim this is actually very
important hit me
all right
this is masala munch every indian south
asian house that you visit
will have a tray
and on that tray they'll just be a
variation of salty
foods to some capacity the scenario
where that would get pulled out is say
tim's parents were in the same
neighborhood as my parents and they
wanted us to get married they go ding
dong like crazy story
tim and i are here in the neighborhood
and my parents would be like really
you came to rancho cordova california
and tim's mom and dad would be like yes
we did
and then my mom and dad would be like
come sit down in the living room and
then we would sit across from each other
awkwardly
as you hear that the blare of the air
conditioner
and our and our parents would just be
like so
what is tim majoring in
and tim your parents would answer
film they'd go
wow
husson's majoring in poli sci
looks like they both have arts degrees
then they would just kind of do vague
banter like that eventually leading to
what is called both bucky hoping that we
say yes and um we ask for each other's
hand in marriage and two families meet
and while that's all happening you would
have
a salty snack by the way i love how
this is how you know it's from india
it's the
the sponsor is airtel
this is good
i mean this is
gonna be blasphemous as you think is
better than
the flaming hot
it's like richer deeper
has just enough masala i can also learn
more about the cell phone plan i get two
gigabytes of free data
[Music]
guys this is how you know i'm doing
pretty good in life my children i hope
when they eventually grow up and they
see this know that we got them they're
snacks from trader joe's it's a pretty
good upgrade uh these for the kids
they're honey grams with sea salt which
to me is a little bit bougie for a
three-year-old and a one-year-old oh
this looks good i feel like these would
be really good frozen
tim these are solid try one
i'm serious
a wedding is happening
so my last one is one of my favorite
snacks to make i usually make it late at
night
after i finished a show i've come home
everybody's asleep and i will make
myself this treat this is an eggo waffle
peanut butter banana sandwich and or
tostada and i'm gonna make it for myself
and tim egger waffle slightly crisp
shout out to tim he didn't completely
let it go all the way to the southern
hemisphere he just
burnt it a little bit as if he wasn't
paying attention but then he
got a hold of the wheel and we didn't
lose this let's listen to the crunch
real quick
oh look at that what a time to be alive
look we have a lot of problems in this
country but my god is our snack
selection amazing
do you like it thinner or thicker tim
then you got it see this the center part
right here we're gonna go with the thin
for tim
guys let's take a quick look
i want to make sure every bite is good
there you go cheers cheers
this is a this is a midnight snack for
you you said midnight to 2 a.m yeah i
might have to start making these for
real yeah they're delicious
you want to cut for milk are you good
this is my happy place
all right those are my favorite snacks
me and tim are about to take off we have
a lot to talk about check me out on the
morning show starting september 17th on
apple and check me out on tour the
king's jester tour starting september
17th get your tickets right now at
hustlemanhash.com
let's go time
[Music]